we are here at the National Museum of
play in rochester new york where they
have one of the world's most amazing
collections of toys and games and yes
video games but we are about to go
behind the scenes we're going to go to
the library to find design documents
from some of your favorite titles
so it's a library I should talk after
but this is where we preserve materials
are not just the games but also all the
background information and that gives us
a full picture of the whole history of
gaming I mean everything from books
about video games to strategy guides and
we also have special collections so in
this case this is a collection that came
from Kenna Roberta Williams yes you're
online what am I looking at here get out
of town is this for birth this is so
this is Roberta Williams yes design
documents for kings quest to write
handwritten in what looks to be pencil
right this is fascinating so what she
would do is she would just write out
like if King graham wants to swim in the
ocean this is the screen that he will
swim on when he swims across it it will
be replaced by the same picture I mean
so basically she just SAT and wrote out
in longhand how the games would go just
unbelievable this is more stuff from
King's Quest right exactly this is
King's Quest 6 i believe and so now it's
a now it's a much much bigger production
here it's not it's not like sheets of
notebook paper and a school binder it's
a view list for each room you can see
this is yeah so now we're a little bit
further into the process of the making
of the game at this point because there
yeah right and you can see Wow
categories here if you want to you can't
go on ebay and by Roberta Williams is uh
original notes from King's Quest but you
can you could buy these if you want to
shell out a whole bunch of money sierra
on-line was just taking their games and
putting them into Ziploc bags like this
i mean this i don't necessarily know if
these are like the original bags but
yeah that's closed right to how you
would buy these games I can't believe
I'm actually going to touch a mystery
house and I just wanted to you know get
myself psyched up for it i mean this is
this is such a you know pivotal release
in video game history and they're just
there aren't any left you know there's
very few left um the extraordinary and
this was Roberta Williams first game
right right yeah this is the one she
created at our kitchen table you know
there's no box that we're missing here
for this game right i mean this is just
how it would
household is how give yourself to read
all this stuff and to look at this is
just amazing right I've never never
never gotten to gotten to see a wizard
of the princess in real life we're glad
I mean the experience to yeah you have
an extra business nice yeah and this of
course has nothing to do with Sierra
here but uh we I mean if we're talking
about gray told you no baggy to pc games
what else then the original castle
wolfenstein wow wow wow if you could dig
through the original design documents
for any video game which one would it be
hey let us know down in the comments and
don't forget subscribe